blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
nonfiction book in just 15 minutes
you can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription
by going to blinkist.com pakman
welcome to the friday show i have a few
stories i want to run through before we
move on to
other things including your questions we
talked
last week about the continued
possibility that donald trump will start
his own political party we also saw a
poll showing
that nearly two-thirds of republican
voters
are in theory willing to leave the
republican party and follow trump to a
new party now of course if donald trump
started a new party
and forget about 64 if donald trump
trump took 50
or 40 or even 30 of republican voters to
a new party
it could spell absolute disaster for the
american rights splitting the vote and
allowing
uh the democratic party to um win
a lot to take a phrase out of donald
trump's vocabulary
there's now another new story and this
is being reported by reuters there are
dozens of former republican officials
who view the republican party as
unwilling to stand
up to donald trump so this is an
anti-trump group
of former republican officials and what
these individuals are saying is
if the republican party won't stand up
to trump and say no we reject trumpism
and we reject trump
they are in discussions to break away
from the republican party and start
their own
and this includes former officials uh in
the republican administrations of ronald
reagan george h.w bush george w bush
as well as even disaffected trump aides
and staffers and uh
political employees this includes some
ex-republican ambassadors this includes
some republican strategists and others
and 120 of them had a zoom call
of course last friday to have a
conversation about this
and the idea is they would say the
republican party has become the party of
trump
we are getting back to principled
conservatism as they call it what that
means is pretending to care about the
debt and deficit let's not mistake that
for anything else but
it doesn't matter because again this
could also be an
absolute and total disaster for the
republican party
one of the people involved is evan
mcmullen you might remember he ran
third party in 2016 former uh cia
agent i believe and he is part of this
movement for a possible splinter party i
have to tell you that this is
fantastic news um imagine if we got but
these would be two gifts
if donald tru you've got the republican
party and within it you have people who
want to stick with trump
and people who want the republican party
to completely denounce
and distance from donald trump you could
have a situation
where so-called principled conservatives
in the republican party
split off and start their own party to
get away from trump and at the same time
donald trump starts his own party and
takes
the hyper pro-trump people away as well
so you could end up with the trump party
taking away from the republican party
the principled conservative
former republicans who are anti-trump
splitting off from the republican party
and then i guess what you'd have left in
the republican party are just generally
people not paying much attention or who
don't don't uh really feel strongly one
way or the other and they just want to
keep voting for people like i don't know
lindsey graham
um and then they stay and you could have
a republican party split three ways
it i i have no interest in giving advice
to these folks about what they should do
i simply recognize the mathematical
realities that
even if trump splits off and takes 15
percent of the party
and these principled conservatives split
off and take
10 or 15 of the party uh that
creates a situation in which republicans
as we know them or in any of these new
iterations
don't win for a decade and uh if there
would ever be an opportunity
for the left to make progress in the
united states it would be that now
unfortunately
the democratic party has shown itself so
often to be
so incompetent that it would probably
still end up being a challenge for a
democratic party
given the gift of a republican party
divided three ways
it would probably still end up being an
uphill battle for the modern democratic
party to make progress but at least
they'd have the opportunity
uh we'll follow it very very interesting
stuff we have a new report out uh that
seeks to answer the question how many
coronavirus deaths can we really
attribute to former president donald
trump and
you know one of the things we knew
intuitively during the trump presidency
and which was concerned confirmed a
number of times by different studies
was that no president could have
predicted every coronavirus death no
president could have even
uh prevented rather rather than
predicted predicted is a different thing
no president could have prevented every
coronavirus death uh we were going to
have many deaths as even countries that
dealt with the virus well had
many deaths but the lack of taking the
virus seriously by the trump
administration from day one
certainly was at least partially
responsible for some of the deaths
a new report now says that 40
of the deaths that took place in 2020
could have been avoided if trump had
merely handled the virus well enough for
the u.s to have the same
not not number of cases but mortality
rate of other wealthy countries at our
level of development
this study was published in the lancet
one of the uh oldest and best known
medical journals
and it explains that the us
had way more deaths a higher mortality
rate during the pandemic than other
rich countries countries including the
uk
and a number of other countries and that
many of the cases and deaths
were avoidable they could have been
avoided by the federal government
response
being more serious from the beginning
rolling out testing earlier on
having stricter guidelines or at least
making it clear that they should be
enforced and that donald trump wanted to
see those enforced
and unfortunately some of these problems
date back even before
donald trump we know that the united
states when it comes to health care
even though we spend a ton of money on
health care we often have worse outcomes
than many
other wealthy developed countries
germany canada
uk so on and so forth and so part of
this
is a bigger problem than donald trump um
a lot of our systems not interacting
well federal and state not interacting
well
so on and so forth but then beyond that
was the failed federal response from
donald trump and i think a lot of us
intuitively
understand this the number of infections
early the lack of
uh just being realistic the lack of
letting actual medical professionals
guide the response and as i've said
before
if indeed donald and we'll talk about
this in a moment when we talk about joe
biden's approval rating
if donald trump had simply said what do
doctors think we should do
what do public health experts think we
should do epidemiologists
immunologists people who know about this
and aren't going to say things like
would the flu vaccine work against
coronavirus as donald trump did back in
i don't remember if it was february or
march
many of these deaths would have been
avoided and we now know that
beyond any doubt whatsoever and the
question
now becomes under new leadership can we
do as well as other countries when it
comes to vaccine distribution
and lowering the mortality rate and
keeping cases
low if and when we get them low so far
the numbers are
cautiously optimistic we had a couple
days uh in the last week
where there were two million
vaccinations done each day if indeed we
have a third vaccine approved sometime
in the near future as it looks like we
will
it's not completely unreasonable to
think that we could get to a steady
2 or 2.5 million vaccine doses per day
and uh we the these are not uh
you know one of the the saddest things
that has taken place
during the pandemic obviously the deaths
and cases and economic
implications and psychological impact
for so many people
have been terrible but one of the
saddest things that that we've also seen
uh has been the realization that the
people in charge really do make a
difference
what the politics are of your governor
in dealing with the pandemic
it really makes a difference whether
there is a competent federal government
response really makes a difference
when you have people like jared kushner
saying well the stockpile is our
stockpile it's not for the states
that's just not a disgusting political
statement that you see on tv
that has a real trickle-down impact and
hopefully we're going to see that
improve
and it seems as though the american
people are confident that it is
improving
uh joe biden with the highest initial
approval rating in 28 years
let's talk about that now this is very
very interesting
president joe biden is
currently experiencing the highest
initial approval rating of any president
dating back 28 years to bill clinton in
1993.
the uh all-america economic survey
has found that joe biden has a 62
approval rating right now his initial
approval rating
that beats the first presidential rating
of barack obama
of george w bush of bill clinton and of
course
of donald trump and in fact joe biden's
initial
rating of 62 approval is 18 points
higher
than that of donald trump uh there are a
number of takeaways here
first of all when we look at these
numbers
and understand that there are hyper
partisan
um enclaves of americans that will
either always approve
or always disapprove of a president
merely based on political party you
realize that the real range it's not
really zero to a hundred
it's probably more like i don't know 20
to 80 or 25 to 75 or whatever so
when you see a rating of 36 that is
much closer to the bottom than it would
seem
because some portion will always approve
of the president
when you see a number like 62 that's
much closer to the top
because because some portion will always
disapprove so number one
the difference between 62 and 36 is much
bigger than merely the difference
between the two numbers when you
understand american politics that's
number one
number two important takeaway is that
this really reinforces that donald trump
could have easily won reelection
if back in march he had simply said
this is serious the doctors know what to
do
let's do what they say oh they say wear
masks we are printing
american flag masks do the patriotic
thing
if trump and his uh um staffers would
were
regularly pictured from the beginning
with the patriotic american flag masks i
know that might violate flag code okay
don't email me about that um donald
trump would have sailed to re-election
as we saw so many world leaders do
who uh dealt with the virus well and
that is confirmed by uh this this
polling much of joe biden's early
approval
is based on his handling of the
coronavirus on which he has a nearly 70
approval rating so
trump could be president right now and
it's because of trump that he is not
we'll continue to follow joe biden's
approval it could go up it could go down
i really don't know these are unique
circumstances in which we find ourselves
but i want to hear from you where do you
believe joe biden's approval will go
and or does it depend on accomplishing
something
like for example getting the coveted
relief checks to americans i believe if
he fails to do it
it will be a political disaster but i do
believe he is going to do it
let me know your thoughts i'm on twitter
at deepakman the david pakman show
at davidpakman.com
[Music]
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly what one of
my favorite apps lets you do
it's called blinkist and what they do is
take thousands of popular nonfiction
books
they condense them down into text or
audio that you can consume in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the
important core insights from each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
nonfiction book
in just 15 minutes i recently read a
brief history of time of course by the
great stephen hawking this is a book
that i have been aware of for so long
and
other things got in the way and it was
fantastic to check it out on blinkist
blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about
eight bucks a month and you get the
entire library
but you can try it totally free and get
twenty five percent off a subscription
when you go to blinkist.com
slash david pakman i've put the link
right underneath this video
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
davidpakman.com
okay let's hear from some folks in the
audience taking
calls via discord at davidpakman.com
discord join the community on discord
it's free i think about
um 11 000 people now on the discord
maybe approaching 12 000 it's a great
thing
all right let's see what's on people's
minds starting with
let's go to grayson from seattle grayson
from seattle you're on the air
hey david can you hear me yes i can
great
um so i was wondering what you think the
future holds for
conservative commentators like stephen
crowder or centrist and i have centrist
in
quotes uh commentators like tim poole
especially was was pretty radio silent
and um i was just wondering what kind of
content can they even produce
now that all their darlings are
terrorist inciters or sympathizers
wait so you're saying crowder has been
radio silent i didn't know that
yeah after january 6th he was pretty
silent like
like one or two low effort tweets i
think he started doing his show
recently again i mean i don't like
watching it so i haven't looked at it
too much
but i mean i just don't know what kind
of argument he has
anymore you know it's i i mean i know
what the argument will be and we're
already
you all you have to do is look at fox
news and oan and newsmax to understand
that there is still a very much alive
uh radical right sort of uh perspective
and it includes going back to all of the
tired old tropes
laura ingram did it on fox news i think
it was monday night where she did you
know this segment about the biden
insurrection and he's welcoming on
dangerous undocumented immigrants and
brown people and all this stuff
and here's the thing that may be so
tired and boring to you and i who are
now looking
to see what will joe biden get done and
can we start restoring the reputation of
the country
but you can do really well uh as an
individual show or channel with a tiny
slice of the american public because
there's 331 million people in the
country so i think that they're going to
do just fine
i mean to people to people like us who
now
we just laugh when we see them go back
to their same talking points
okay we're not in their audience but i
think they're going to do fine
yeah fair enough i think you're right
and then i had a quick argentine lingo
question if you don't mind oh sure of
course so
i've heard my argentine friends say
boludo to each other
right can i get away with saying that in
a friendly way or is that a bit too
aggressive to say to my friend
i think it's fine i mean it's so it's
not you know it's not a thing where
you're just kind of saying kind of like
hey you prick you know you're
it's not uh it's not racially
discriminatory it's not
uh you're not picking on any particular
religion or anything like that i think
it's fine
and it'll show you to be sort of like an
insider to the lingo i think you're
you're fine with that
perfect well i think this might have
been a perfect call this was a perfect
phone call absolutely thank you uh
grayson from seattle
great to hear from you uh and hope to
hear from you
again uh why don't we talk next to chris
from ocala is is it pronounced ocala or
ocala florida
hello yes that's you hey
david what's up yes it's uh ocala ocala
florida
or away from orlando got it what's going
on
not much so uh first off i wanna say
thank you um
for everything you do man i mean uh
beforehand uh before i even saw your
show i
i was having a bit of trouble finding
any uh left
leaning um uh talk shows i i feel like
i've been more exposed to like the
people
like uh ben shapiro or dave rubin and it
was really hard finding the opposite and
when i
uh delve into your channel i was able to
uh uh completely switch my views on
everything i mean what you
said made a lot of sense and everything
and uh
i just want to say thank you for that um
i i i have a
question about um uh biden's
age um the wright has been pushing this
propaganda that uh he's too old in that
conley harris is gonna take over and
everything and i know that's a bit of a
stretch but i mean at the same time i
recognize
that the guy is 78 years old um
should i be expecting that something
could happen in the near future i mean i
know that you said before that wealthier
people tend to
um live longer like with donald trump i
mean even though he's
uh severely obese i mean the guy's a
freaking whale
um he does have a lot of money so
it's expected that he'll live a rather
long lifespan
listen um joe so so you're absolutely
right that
class has a huge interaction with life
expectancy in the united states
but i don't know that it's that
different between multi-millionaires
and billionaires so joe but from the
standpoint of economic class joe biden
at this point is a a wealthy guy
and i don't think that's really the
issue you do point out the risk factors
uh donald trump is uh quite overweight
joe biden
is not uh donald trump doesn't exercise
he regularly saw joe biden riding his
bike uh donald trump uh
is proud of eating an unhealthy diet as
far as i know biden's diet is healthier
but biden is a few years older here's
the reality um
when you look at actuarial tables for a
74 year old and a 78 year old
sure the 78 year old on average is more
likely to die in the next year than the
74 year old by a relatively small margin
but in both cases you're talking about
people who are in their mid to late 70s
so
whatever concerns you had about donald
trump along these lines
should be sort of similar about joe
biden and that maybe the country would
be better served having someone who's
not in their mid to late 70s but i don't
know
about you know if you were fine with
trump's age and health
i don't see it being dramatically
different with joe biden
right okay so i mean real like
realistically speaking i mean
i shouldn't really be expecting a
president harris anytime soon right i
mean
the guy's being taken care of listen
he's getting the best health care anyone
can get as president of the united
states
and the problem is we can make
assessments about
what we expect from large populations
making predictions about any one
person's health is very difficult to do
and that that applies to any any
individual
right okay all right chris i'm gonna let
you go because your phone won't stop
buzzing in the background and it's kind
of getting to be a little bit irritating
to the audience so we're gonna we're
gonna
go but i really do appreciate hearing
from you let's go next to zayler from
rhode island
sailor from rhode island you're on the
air
sailor from rhode island yes sorry it
took me a while to meet myself how are
you doing today david i'm doing well
thank you
so you did a video actually very
recently
about dog whistles and you discuss dog
whistles used on the right
and dog whistles that might be used as
on the left and you mentioned that
some of the leftist dog whistles are
either boring or there's not too many of
them
um i i didn't see you mention though
sometimes
i feel like even the word use of the
word elite
can be considered a dog whistle by both
the right and the left
usually on the right it's referring to
like their hatred of jewish people
on the left uh the extremists sometimes
just use it as like a catch-all for like
capitalists like
um just like capitalist in general uh
some of the more socialist types use it
in that way
oh what do you think about that i don't
you know so you're certainly right
that sometimes when the left uses the
term elites they're talking about
economic elites which applies to rich
people
and corporate ceos and that type of
thing i guess i don't i'm not saying
i don't know that it's a dog whistle in
the sense that everybody understands
what they mean by that
one of the things about dog whistles is
when you blow a dog whistle the dog
hears it but
you know humans don't really hear it so
i just would disagree that it's it's
definitely a
co it's coded language but it's coded
language everybody seems to sort of
understand so i don't know that elites
in that usage really counts as a dog
whistle yeah that makes sense actually
that now that you mentioned that
excellent well
that's really the only question i had
prepared so i just hope you
have i hope you're doing well and
keeping warm thank you
yes zayler from rhode island appreciate
the call remember everybody the lesson
from uh
from zayler there is always make sure to
set your discord to uh silent or do not
disturb or whatever it is so we don't
hear those annoying noises
let's go next to sarah from one of my
favorite cities in the world
montreal quebec canada sarah you're on
the air
hello can you hear me yes i can okay
uh so i guess i just wanted to know uh
what do you think about canada designing
the proud boys as a terrorist group
i think because yeah when i when i was
asked about it last week
i i obviously agreed colloquially but i
didn't understand
what it meant legally speaking in canada
and people have emailed me since and
explained that
by designating a a terrorist group it
actually
allows law enforcement more mechanisms
and leeway
for um pursuing and prosecuting the
group and that it has
legal significance in canada so i agree
with it
in the general sense and it sounds like
it will be useful to canada as well
yeah do you think there's gonna be any
similar things done like that in the
states or
you don't really think nothing's gonna
happen about that
i don't know i don't know i mean
obviously it's more likely that
abide in white house would push for
designating the proud boys as a
terrorist group
than in a trump white house i don't know
that it's a priority for the biden white
house to do that
okay uh other follow-up question because
they would talk about the
martial law in the u.s when the capital
thing happened right
i don't i don't know if you knew about
the law war was it the
missouri so it's like the war measures
were enacted in quebec in the 70s
and the army took control of the country
at the province because
of like terrorist group the flq i know
if you heard anything about that
i'm not familiar with that particular
incident but i've done some reading
about
instances short-term instances in many
countries over the last 40
50 years where there have been
declarations where the military does
take over and and
see you know one of the problems sarah
is that when we look at historical
examples
there are many of historical examples of
martial law being declared
by authoritarian dictators who want to
remain in power and then you also have
examples where
there was a legitimate use and reason
for that declaration and so you really
have to look at the details of every
situation
yeah no for sure uh anyways i suggest
you look into it i know all the
information is mostly in french
yeah there's like a bias between the two
languages of how the interpret the
events
but if you have time my french reading
isn't bad
you know sometimes when i watch a french
show i will watch it with the french
subtitles and that's actually enough for
me to understand it
okay that's cool uh my favorite quebec
is kind of the communist hellscape the
u.s
fears uh so i love quebec i have to tell
you it's so great there it's such a
you're it's it's the uh
it's such a european experience you know
yeah well one day the borders will open
again and you can come over
i would i would love to go and so are
you what general area in montreal are
you in
uh i'm in like the southwest so it's
like verderso it's like very uh
working class kind of thing but um i'm
kind of like the uh i guess
yuppy which is like i work in video
games so i have a little bit of money
i'm still full student debt so i live in
a kind of working class neighborhood
now south west that's not like the
atwater market right at water market is
more like southwest
yeah it's like close to that it's
because montreal's directions are weird
because the north is the north of the
river
without the true north so everything is
really confusing for me
there's a similar thing in buenos aires
where what seem
oftentimes what is north on the map the
city is kind of rotated
relative to the river and so yeah and in
fact manhattan is the same thing
often times manhattan is portrayed as
the avenues
running perfectly north south but that's
just for visual aids
it's actually at an angle that's
interesting yeah it's it's
yeah it's a it's a weird things and
people get confused when they first come
in but
sarah one more question for you have you
ever been to the vietnamese
food stall at the atwater market uh
i have not okay i highly recommend it i
highly recommend it
okay cool okay there's a lot of great
food montreal there is it's like a lot
of food to eat
um but yeah thank you for taking my call
all right my pleasure sarah from
montreal great to hear from you
we're going to take a very quick break
but if you're holding on to talk to me
don't hang up unless you're furious that
i've not picked up your call already but
hang on because we're going to take a
few more calls right after the break
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the number one funding source for the
david pakman show
has been and continues to be membership
and membership is not just a feel-good
thing
you get access to the world famous bonus
show every single day
just for members as well as commercial
free audio
and video feeds of the show day in
and day out you can sign up for
membership very very quickly
at joinpackman.com that's join
pakman.com
if the normal prices strike you as high
by
all means use the coupon code better21
all one word all lowercase become a
member today
welcome back to the david pakman show
okay we're speaking to folks um who
presumably are fans of the show
although sometimes they're not a via the
david pakman show discord which you can
find
at davidpakman.com
discord let's go next to
uh let's go to irina irina from
from where from where
irina you're on the air cyric
from zurich wow that's a that's a
perfect city
europe yes from europe oh europe i
thought you said zurich switzerland
switzerland yes that's right yeah oh you
are in switzerland okay
uh yes well i didn't think i would have
the chance to talk to you
and i'm very grateful for your um
comments that you give thank you
and also it's interesting to see the
press briefings
um of the new president biden
and it's so it's good to compare it i'm
not
yeah that's i'm very it's it's very
informative
and helpful and often when i get
angry you you make a good comment so i'm
very glad to hear that it's it's very
interesting
irena would you say that the opinion of
the united states
now that trump has been removed and joe
biden has been put in
is it improving is our reputation within
switzerland improving at all
uh i think so i think so okay
i mean um of course i
i follow it uh you know i also listened
to
mr chomsky noam chomsky and
yeah i hope that the biden
administration will be more
more strong maybe you know maybe at this
point they will
really uh just continue to
do the things which are necessary for a
humane
democratic society yes and i hope
here in zurich in zurich that this riot
on the 6th of january had a
repercussion that the crazy brother of
a vegetarian
chain tippits they have a brother
and he i don't know whom he wrote but
it's written in our
newspaper um he wrote to a military
officer to um to uh
imprison our secrecy federal government
yes because of the
of the corona measure
measures they took and um
yes i mean he was totally inspired that
was only a few days
after the riots in the um
in washington dc and
i was glad that i mean here it counts as
crazy but
you know i think i hope that
uh trump will be um
uh impeached and convicted of course yes
he has been impeached but now the trial
yeah concussions
yeah he will i mean that he will have a
uh really that that it's clear he did a
crime
right right because this will have
repercussions to europe
and i am sure of it we are so
american-centered
that um you know europe is still very
american-centered
still no doubt about it arena thank you
so much for the call i'm gonna let you
go because i have a lot of people
waiting
always great to hear from our friends in
switzerland
switzerland one of my favorite favorite
countries
let's speak next to
uh radical capitalist jack
radical capitalist jack you are
on the area just had uh one question is
uh
do you think anything further is going
to happen to uh marjorie taylor green
um i think she stands a chance getting
removed from uh her position or now
no i don't think so uh if you look in
history at when uh members of congress
have actually been expelled
it's been five uh two of them were
actually convicted of crimes
and that's why they got expelled the
other three were supporting
the confederacy in the civil war so it's
it's i i don't see it as likely
all right thank you my pleasure okay
there we go there is uh there is jack
uh radical capitalist jack let's go next
to patrick from vernon hills patrick
from vernon hills you're on the air
hey david how's it going it's going well
uh
i guess i have a question about
where we go forward with our media
ecosystem
i read a book recently that looked at
the
historical effects of networks in
society specific a good parallel was
when the printing press was created and
then
christianity shattered into a thousand
pieces and
we had decades of war after that because
everybody could read their own
interpretation of the bible instead of
it all coming through the catholic
church
and it feels now like media has been
shattered
into a thousand pieces and we all just
get
wherever we want and you know talking to
conservatives they don't even they
haven't even read the same stories
they've read and we're
just operating from a completely
different set of information
and we can't even talk about ideas we're
just talking about
what's true and what's not true you know
i love that you're bringing this up i
love that you're bringing this up
because
um you know one of the things there was
a very interesting discussion on the
david pakman show subreddit recently
where someone posted
uh they they did it in sort of an attack
way but i still appreciated it they said
you know
um listening to the david pakman show
watching the david pakman show alone is
not going to make you informed
or educated or smart or whatever and
they meant it i think as an attack but
i don't see it i agree with that and one
of the things that i have
been talking about for a long time is um
my
my hope with this show is not
that people end up believing all the
same things that i believe
and my hope is not that i become the
sole
source of commentary for people what i
hope to do with this show
is to be part of the commentary diet and
hopefully expose people to the
importance
of reading economics and reading history
and reading
sociology and philosophy and
one of the real concerns with a lot of
this right wing drivel that's out there
is the same thing we heard from trump
which was only i can fix it
only i tell you the truth you're not
being told the truth here or there and
this is fake news and that's fake news
and all of this stuff what you're
pointing out is maybe
i don't know if you're deliberately
pointing this out or not but i'm going
to pretend you are because it's such a
great point
it's really important for us to be
consuming
lots of writing that has sort of stood
the test of time
ideas and books that are still being
read
decades after they've been written
sometimes centuries after they've been
written you know really long time and
nasim nasim talib in the black swan and
anti
anti-fragile writes about this you
really want to be
starting with your base and that should
be you know
really reading texts of his history
economics philosophy et cetera
then on top of that you place news
actual news reporting that's going on
and the top of the pyramid
pyramid should be shows like mine where
i'm not giving you
an opinion on an empty platform
hopefully you are coming
in with the base of the pyramid and
i'm just giving you my thoughts and we
all are sharing a lot of this
information now unfortunately as you're
pointing out a lot of people come in and
just listen to opinion shows
and don't know history economics
philosophy science etc that's a problem
but but you're
uh i'm i'm off on a rampage but you're
making a beautiful point
yeah i think that's um not quite what i
was getting at but pretty close
i like your hierarchy of knowledge that
you
um laid out there right i'm just in a
every year i'm just concerned that
you know people aren't doing that and
they are
yes really getting their information
from the top of the pyramid they don't
have their base
no no your your assessment is correct
that's what's happening and it's
horrible
i can't talk to people because i'm just
we we don't even have a common
set of facts to talk about and it's so
frustrating just
talking about is this true or is this
not true i
like climate change i you know climate
change is real
what do we do about it but we're stuck
on is climate change real
yeah the interesting question is what do
we do about it there's a lot of good
weight
there's thousands of ways to solve the
problem but
like alcoholics anonymous you know the
first step is admitting you have a
problem
you can't do anything until you get past
that first step
absolutely yeah i'm i'm reading a
merchants of doubt now about
the industry of denying that
tobacco smoke is harmful to health
denying that acid rain is bad denying
that there's climate change and
there's entire industries based around
furthering doubt about
that and so it's not uh part of it is
uneducated people but also part of it is
very well funded industries that want
people to doubt the facts
yep all right thank you so much i love
your show all right thank you great
great call
appreciate it very very important things
being brought up let's go to alex from
orange county alex from orange county
you're on the air
hey david can you hear me yes i can
awesome
so um i remember you said
every midterm election if the if the
president wins the opposing signs
um also win um why do you think that no
no so that's that's not always the case
but that's
it's often the case not always okay
um is there a reason why that happens do
people just stay home
and assume oh we're all good or
something like that yeah i think it's a
combination of things so i think
when when you have one party win a
presidential election
um and then you have a midterm two years
later there's a couple different things
that are going on one
in general there's a lower turnout in
midterms than there is in presidential
elections so by its very nature that
means that
uh whoever is more motivated in the
midterm has a better shot at being able
to turn the election
in their favor and uh what motivates
people to get out and vote well
it's their opponent winning so when you
see one party win in a presidential
it will often be more motivational to
the opponents of that
uh a person to the the members of the
party that is in opposition to the
winner of the white house
and so you'll see them come out in
larger numbers in the following midterms
that's typically the way it goes i don't
know that that's the way 2022 will go
though
um okay um can i ask you one more thing
of course um um after the
2020 elections do you trust um poly data
at all even though like it really felt
like um joe biden really had this in the
bag
but we were all pretty nervous you know
when election day happened
i mean listen um the the not the the
polling data
certainly was skewed more in the biden
direction
than what ended up being the actual
outcome
now joe biden was projected to win the
popular vote
and he did and joe biden was projected
to win the electoral vote and he did but
there's no denying that the margin
was not what many expected it to be
including in states like wisconsin as as
an example
so you know the trusting polling data is
very black and white i think we have to
understand the limitations of polling
but at the same time understand that
um uh it's uh
it is not as precise precise as many of
us would want and as i spoke about with
david shore
not long ago he pointed out that the
idea of
we now have such politicization of
polling that there are certain
populations that will respond to polling
in a certain way
and that can skew the results we have to
be we have to account for that that's a
real thing
okay well um that'll be all david and
thank you for taking my call my pleasure
great to hear from you really appreciate
it
uh and then why don't we talk to uh
how about we speak to antonioni from
chicago i hope i'm pronouncing that
correctly hey can you hear me david yes
i can
yeah no that's that's correct
pronunciation love it um
big fan of the show thanks for taking
the call
thank you so much of what i have to ask
is about um
code relief and budget reconciliation
okay
i kind of okay so i guess i need to
refresh a little bit on the current
current status and the next action step
so
right now we're trying to pass covert
relief through budget reconciliation
yes which that passed the house correct
uh yes it did now you know now you have
me doubting where it stands right now
yeah yeah
and i didn't mean to put you on on spot
here because i realized there's so much
going on yeah and there is always a new
update so like if you don't know one of
these questions like i totally get it
yeah no i'm not up to speed as to it i
know that democrats
believe they need to move forward
without republicans and that that
clearly is the case i actually am unsure
where the bill is right now
yeah i don't know if it passed the house
or not because i thought it did
and then there was still debate you know
about the income threshold
that who's going to get the uh you know
the relief indeed so i was like okay
maybe it didn't pass
the house um anyway so i guess
what i'm going to is i really wanted to
know your opinion on
do you think reoccurring relief is
even going to be a thing or is this
going to be one of the
i mean if you had a guess i know it's
really hard we're in a pandemic you
don't know
how this is going to play out but we're
seeing how long this process takes and
it's
i guess it's not too long you know it's
expectable it's been a month
like since bidens came into office um
but it's for that 1400 and you know and
there's some progressives fighting for
two thousand dollars
recurring and i just don't
like how long is like what's going to be
the process for that because i know we
have to get
this 1400 yeah through through budget
reconciliation
so what would the process then be to get
another 2
000 yeah you're exactly right uh i i
hate to rain on anybody's parade
i don't think recurring payments are
going to happen and
uh there are people that love the idea
of sort of like pandemic
basic income in a sense um if
things particularly as you're pointing
out it's
a lot of work just to get fourteen
hundred dollars done
and i hope that we we start to recover
from the pandemic both from a health
standpoint and an economic standpoint
and if that happens uh i don't know i
don't even think
that you're going to have republic
democrats in the senate going for
recurring payments so i i want to be as
real with the audience as i can
i don't see it i don't see it happening
i don't see it either no no i agree
um and i guess one of the last questions
that
has to still do with this is there's
there's all this talk about you know
there's a lot of democrats
were fighting to lower that threshold to
50k yes um for the relief
do we who who are they because joe
manchin is kind of like
you know the mascot for them but i don't
know who the other ones are
and i guess they're not they're they're
going anonymous does that
seem to be what the issue is i don't
have the list in front of me but this is
exactly what we were talking about when
joe biden won
where we were saying you know if we're
assuming
everything will be 50 50 and then kamala
gets it through
we're forgetting that there are
occasionally
democrats who don't just sign their
names to what joe biden wants or to what
the bulk of the democrats in the senate
want and
and we are seeing that yeah i'm again
obviously i just i don't know that it
needs to be said i'm against lowering
the threshold to 50
000. yeah okay i mean
that's it and i um you know i hope i saw
how like kamala was
interviewing with you know the newspaper
where joe manchin is from or whatever
trying to push him to get that through
and i
i hope there's more tactics like that to
push these
um people that are more center to the
left and
this time certainly yeah awesome thanks
so much for taking the call i appreciate
it all right antonio from chicago great
to hear from you
uh we're gonna go to a break sorry i
wasn't able to get to everybody i do my
best but i can never get to everybody
uh there's always more we will take a
quick break and be back with more right
after this
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show is audience
supported media and you can contribute
any amount you want on patreon as little
as one dollar per month
plus you can get the daily bonus show
world famous at this point
and the daily commercial free tv show by
making those pledges
at patreon.com slash david pakman show
this is audience supported media we
depend on the support of our viewers and
listeners
whether you listen to the podcast watch
on youtube or watch us
on tv or even listen on the radio
patreon.com
slash david pakman show
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
all right let's get to uh audience
questions for the week
first one uh increasingly relevant as
the vaccine rollout continues
and vaccines are made avail available to
more and more americans
david do you know people personally who
are refusing to get the coronavirus
vaccine
you know i do and the i don't really
know
conspiracy theory types personally who
are saying oh it'll alter your dna or
you're going to get microchipped by the
vaccine i know that a lot of people
believe that because i've seen the data
i've seen the surveys but i don't know
any of those folks personally what i'm
seeing mostly in the people i know
who are saying they're not planning to
get vaccinated or at least not for now
um is lack of information they're just
ignorant to the fact so like as one
example a friend of mine a couple of
weeks ago said
um i'm not going to uh i'm not even
going to think about
getting a vaccine until they do the
phase 3 trials
and i explained to him for the approved
vaccines phase 3 trials have been done i
mean if
the phase 3 trials have been done for
months and
we got that data in november december
and it was reviewed by the fda
and then an emergency use authorization
was put forward and he said really oh i
didn't know and i said yeah i mean that
you you need the phase three data there
was a discussion last
summer about do we not
do we do an emergency use order before
finishing phase three if the data looks
good it wasn't done
phase three has been done and once i
explained that to him he said oh
well i guess i'll look into it now what
was really kind of scary is he works in
the healthcare field
and we've we've read about um a number
of a significant portion of nurses and
others working in the healthcare field
who are saying i'm not going to get the
vaccine so that's
some some folks that i'm hearing from uh
who say they're not going to get it it's
something like that they don't think
it's been approved they don't think
phase three is done or whatever the case
may be
but phase three is done and there is an
emergency use authorization
the other people that i personally know
who are
you know refusing is a weird term now
because most of them aren't yet eligible
but who are telling me they don't
a plan to get a vaccine um is that
they're sort of saying it as
from a libertarian perspective like
they're against forced vaccination
and i kind of point out to them if
you're
opting not to get it clearly you're not
forced
and then this gets into this weird
discussion about well
if in order to fly you are required to
have it
you are being forced to get it and i i
try to explain there's a difference
between
mandatory and required for certain
activities
and i end up kind of coming back to the
same place from this libertarian
perspective which is
as a libertarian do you respect the
right of
just hypothetically delta airlines to
say
we require people who want to fly with
us to present proof of vaccination after
a certain
date and they end up usually in a
pretzel of some kind
where they are uber libertarians who
think businesses shouldn't be regulated
they should be allowed to do whatever
they want
and yet somehow they want to be able to
decide what delta's policy should be and
if they want to fly without a vaccine
they should be allowed to you've got
you've got to be a little more
consistent here and um
there is not going to be a mandatory
vaccination from the government
there's no legal basis to do that but
that being said
there are all sorts of different
institutions that might say if you want
to choose to avail yourself of our
product or service or to do business
with us
one of our requirements is that you be
vaccinated
and this is not legally
problematic this is not constitutionally
an issue etc now in terms of
the number of people remaining in the us
who don't plan to get the vaccine
i don't know whether to say we're in a
good place or we're not in a good place
there was a point
months and months ago where more than
half the country
said they did not plan to get a
coronavirus vaccine that number is down
to about a third of the country and it
continues to go down
it's good that the percentage of people
who don't plan to get it has basically
dropped by half
the concerning part is that
i don't know that with two-thirds of
adult getting the vaccine two-thirds of
adults getting it and one-third not that
we're going to reach herd immunity and
that's really the concern at this point
dr fauci and others have said
in particular since we're not going to
be vaccinating kids in
in the immediate uh we need close to all
adults to get the vaccine particularly
with these more
transmissible variants to really have
herd immunity and protection so the
there's good news here which is vaccine
hesitancy is declining
the bad news is there's still a lot of
people including
otherwise educated individuals
who think everything from the vaccine
will alter your dna
to it'll allow the government to track
you oh oh oh
which reminds me there is one
acquaintance this is not a friend but
it's an acquaintance
who posted to facebook not long ago
uh i have some reasonable concerns about
the vaccine i'm not
saying i'm not going to get it but i i
do believe
this that and that it could be used to
track my location
and a lot of our shared friends started
trying to talk her off the ledge
i just had to unfriend it's just i can't
do it guys
i can't do it and i know many of you
have come up against the same situation
okay next question today david
can democrats add puerto rico and
washington dc as states
without republican involvement so
there's two answers to this legally
speaking
constitutionally speaking admitting a
new state
is not a legislative matter so
the legislative filibuster that is
possible in the senate on some issues
should not actually apply and as the
weak
recently published in recent years both
democrats and republicans have in effect
agreed the filibuster shouldn't apply to
certain constitutional matters not
covered by article 1
which lays out the design of congress
and its legislative powers
the admission of new states is not part
of article one
and it's something distinct and as a
result
in theory democrats don't need
republicans to make washington dc or
puerto rico
states now historically
this is a different matter um the
idea from the framers appears to be
they clearly designated the addition of
states as not requiring a
super majority um but
at the same time it is not
particularly likely that from a
practical political standpoint
democrats would go it completely alone
and from the people i've spoken to that
are
aids to elected officials there's the
belief that it is
if it is not bipartisan to some degree
um that it would be unlikely to happen
and so although from a very fundamental
legal standpoint
democrats could say we are voting to
make d.c estate
and it could be 50 50 in the senate and
then kamala harris could cast the
deciding vote that certainly could be
done uh i have not spoken to anyone who
thinks that it's going to actually be
done that way and that more than likely
if democrats were dead set on making dc
and or puerto rico states
even if republicans weren't uh thrilled
with it that there would be some kind of
negotiation
where republicans would get something
now what that something is i don't
actually know
one other thought on this i don't know
for sure that every democrat in the
senate
in the absence of some republicans who
want to make dc and or puerto rico
states i don't know that every
democratic senator would actually go for
it so there's actually a question as to
whether you get to 50 50 would joe
manchin
vote to make puerto rico and dc and or
dc states
if not a single republican in the senate
plans to do it i don't know the answer
to that
and there is the feeling that there are
at least
one or two democratic senators who
without some republican support for the
additional states
would not go for it the real question to
me is are we ever going to find out the
answer to this
is this actually going to be something
democrats try to do in the next two
years
as they control the white house the
house and the senate i wish i could say
yes
it's not completely clear to me hey
david uh i'm in
i'm from australia and i'm trying to
figure out why so many americans do not
vote
isn't it obvious that it is just the
fundamental basic participation
in your democracy and that it is the
starting point for all political
involvement
yes uh yes i you know for me i have said
many times
i don't believe in this stuff of if you
don't vote you don't get to complain
that seems kind of silly and and
reductive uh
but i do think that anybody
who cares at all about the country they
live in
should as a minimum be voting in
addition to whatever else they are doing
now the question of why more people
don't vote is a good question it's easy
to say well more people don't vote
because it's not mandatory
that's not what what i think is really
the interesting part the more
interesting part to me is
what are the reasons that people choose
not to vote
and there's a very interesting study of
non-voters
and you can find this on the 538 website
um and it looked at why voters versus
non-voters
uh end up not voting rather it compared
the reasons that people who never vote
don't vote
versus the reasons that people who
sometimes vote
don't end up voting one of the reasons
that non-voters choose never to vote is
they believe that it doesn't matter who
wins
nothing will change for people like them
and unfortunately this is one of those
kind of fallacious beliefs you know we
hear this idea that sometimes people
will say
elections really never come down to one
vote
so therefore my vote doesn't matter so
i'm going to stay home and while it's
true that elections
rarely come down to one vote
particularly national elections
um if everybody who had that thought
occurred to them
stayed home or voted then you actually
would be able to
change the outcomes and maybe influence
what your day-to-day life is like
so that that's a really unfortunate one
one of the reasons it feels like things
don't change is so many people aren't
voting if everybody was voting things
would actually change
um another reason that non-voters often
don't vote
is they believe the system is too broken
to be fixed by voting that's sort of a
version of the same thing
um and then um some folks who believe
that because of where they live
their vote doesn't matter which is a
direct um
critique of the electoral college and
then lastly
one of the reasons that a lot of
non-voters cite for not voting is
they're not sure
if they can vote which is really just
depressing
there are situations in which you would
not be allowed to vote because of a
criminal conviction and we know that
that's being dealt with at the state
level in a variety of different states
but other than not knowing if you are
registered or knowing when you can
register i mean
the idea that people don't vote because
they're not sure if they can vote that's
a failure of the system for sure
and then you have to look at which party
has an interest in reducing voter
turnout and of course we know that it's
been the republican party
we know that the republican party has
covertly
been working on reducing turnout for
decades and
overtly doing it for at least 10 or 12
years uh check out the mike turzai video
back in 2012 i believe it is where he
openly says
voter id is going to deliver
pennsylvania to mitt romney
so that's just a depressing reality now
we could solve a lot of these problems
if we eliminate this idea of voter
registration if it's simply
you turn 18 and you're a citizen you can
vote you don't need to register
that resolves a lot of the issue as to
whether one is allowed to vote that
should be done
um if we uh uh deal with this issue
of uh have i been purged or do i need id
or not
all of these things they when we talk
about voter there's a reason it's called
voter suppression it really does
suppress the vote
um and then of course people feeling
like the system is broken i mean to some
degree i sympathize with them
and at the same time i recognize that
the the lower
participation is in elections the more
broken it's going to be the more the
system will be representative
of those who choose to vote so the
voting
voting is is just the starting point i
get that voting isn't everything
but it is depressing when i see you know
52 turnout
uh fortunately we were over 60 this
november but this is a real problem in
the united states
i don't know that you really solve it in
a deep way
simply by making voting mandatory my
birth country of argentina has mandatory
voting
uh i don't know that it in itself gives
us less corrupt
outcomes but that's a bigger issue and
probably one for a different day
we've got a great bonus show for you
today get instant access by becoming a
member
at joinpakman.com
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
nonfiction book in just 15 minutes
you can try it for free and get 25
percent off a subscription
by going to blinkist.com david pakman